un juicio de dimensiones geopolíticas es
la séptima vista del juicio contra la
basquetbolista estadounidense brittney
griner acusada de tráfico de drogas y
detenida en rusia desde febrero pese a
declararse culpable greener alegó que el
aceite de cannabis que portaba no tenía
fines de contrabando su familia lleva
meses pidiendo que el gobierno
estadounidense acelere los trámites para
traerla de nuevo a casa
les pido su ayuda para seguir luchando
por el regreso seguro y rápido de
britney a casa asegurémonos de que a
esta administración sabe que tiene
nuestro apoyo para hacer lo que sea
necesario y no nos vamos a callar hasta
que ya está a salvo en casa
gracias por vuestro amor nuestras voces
vuestras oraciones estamos con reading
rain
para buscar una solución el ejecutivo de
joe biden pidió un intercambio de
prisioneros una propuesta que según la
casa blanca recibió una contraoferta de
mala fe
como saben queremos ver a breivik
trainer en casa queremos ver a paul
willem en casa están detenidos
injustamente hemos sido muy claros al
respecto presentamos una oferta
sustancial y queremos tener una
conversación de buena fe sobre eso
queremos asegurarnos de que ésta se haga
lo antes posible lo que hemos oído es de
mala fe
el kremlin por su parte dijo que graner
podría apelar la sentencia o solicitar
clemencia cuando se emita el veredicto
mientras continúan las negociaciones sin
dar fechas concretas
si hablamos de un intercambio de
prisioneros entre rusia y eeuu este tema
se discutió hace más de un año durante
la reunión de ginebra entre los
presidentes putin y bytes allí acordaron
autorizar a personas competentes para
tratar estos temas
mientras se dirime la situación procesal
de la basquetbolista que podría
enfrentar una pena de 10 años de prisión
en paralelo se ponen de relieve las
tensiones entre washington y moscú